[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedriger siri ihnen allen einen schönen
sonntagabend um 7 wir bringen sie in
aller kürze auf den stand der dinge und
sportlich tut das heute abend für uns
norbert könig mit großen tennis und das
sehen wir gleich im überblick und den
schauen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam an
mehr infektionen steigende
impfbereitschaft auch die zahl der erst
impfungen nimmt wieder zu
ausschreitungen in den niederlanden
corona proteste münchen die zweite nacht
in folge in straßenschlachten mit
festnahmen und verletzten
und triumph in zwei sätzen tennis
olympiasieger alexander zverev ist ltp
weltmeister
in der debatte um eine allgemeine
impfpflicht signalisiert jetzt
schleswig-holsteins
cdu-ministerpräsident günther zustimmung
wenn es nicht anders ginge wäre er auch
bereit diesen schritt zu gehen sagte er
der zeitung die welt am freitag hatte
sich bayerns ministerpräsident so
ähnlich geäußert aktuell verzeichnet
viele ärzte allerdings wieder eine
enorme nachfrage nach vakzinen lena
sünder bruch berichtet in dieser praxis
in kranichfeld in thüringen hat man in
diesen tagen den eindruck die im kapelle
wirken wie viele für eine spritze
herkommen haben sie schon aufgehört zu
zählen jetzt der anstoß und impfungen
ist ja groß insbesondere die büste
impfungen sind sehr stark nachgefragt
aber auch erstimpfungen zweitimpfung
sind jeden tag dabei einige haben die
wieder steigenden infektionszahlen dazu
bewegt sich zum ersten mal impfen zu
lassen
weil ich mich in andere schützen möchte
und weil auch die meine freunde in der
schule angefangen haben und ich will
dann so dachte ja okay vielleicht dass
es doch sicher ich wollte erstmal
abwarten wie sich das so entwickelt seit
dem beginn der debatte um eine
impfpflicht nimmt auch die zahl der
erste impfungen zu zuletzt waren es mehr
als 60.000 an einem tag wenigstens 70,4
prozent der bevölkerung sind nun
mindestens einmal geimpft aktuell ist
die impfbereitschaft hoch helfen wir das
laut experten aber erst langfristig
über 18 jahre
wenig aber es ist natürlich trotzdem
außerordentlich wichtig das zu erreichen
damit wir im kommenden jahr ruhiger sein
können dass es nicht auch noch eine
fünfte welle geht die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz hatte
bereits im juni darauf gedrängt die
impfkampagne weiter voranzutreiben doch
mit beginn des wahlkampfs gingen
wertvolle zeit verloren um die vierte
welle zu stoppen der wahlkampf hat auf
keinen fall geholfen also das system war
während des wahlkampfs keine rolle
gespielt hat war nicht gut aber
wichtiger waren tatsächlich die wochen
nach dem wahlkampf seit spätestens fünf
wochen müssen wir sagen also hätten wir
reagieren müssen die impfkampagne ist
wieder angelaufen doch mit den
steigenden zahlen wächst auch der druck
auf die politik
politik unter druck angesichts dieser
aktuellen corona zahlen das robert koch
institut meldet 42
1727 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind 9000 229 mehr als vor
einer woche
75 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
hinzu und die sieben tage instituts
steigt auf jetzt 3
172,7
die niederlande sind seit heute hoch
risikogebiet wer ungeimpft von dort ein
reist der muss in quarantäne
das infektionsgeschehen hatte zuletzt
immer weiter zugenommen die aktuelle
incidents liegt bei 800 1,2 seit einer
woche ist das land im teil lockdown
geschäfte schließen früher die menschen
sollen wieder von zu hause aus arbeiten
gegen diese maßnahmen gab es gewaltsame
proteste und zwar schon die zweite nacht
in folge wie florian neu hand berichtet
diesmal passierte es vor allem in der
hauptstadt den haag hunderte randalierer
setzten in der nacht zu sonntag autos
und fahrräder in brand bewarfen
polizisten mit feuerwerkskörpern
es sind radikale impfgegner
gewaltbereite hooligans und von der
schließung des nachtlebens verärgerte
jugendliche die sich da treffen wie am
abend zuvor in rotterdam wo
regierungsvertreter hinterher von einer
orgie der gewalt sprechen
das hat nichts mehr mit protest zu tun
das ziel nur noch darauf ab die polizei
zu provozieren und anzugreifen anfang
vom politik angesichts überlasteter
intensivstationen gilt in den
niederlanden seit einer woche einen teil
lockdown geschäfte schließen spätestens
um 20 uhr zu hause dürfen niederländer
maximal vier personen empfangen für
größten protest aber sorgt die geplante
zweijährige dass bald nur noch geimpfte
und genesene etwa in restaurants dürfen
die polarisierung in der nähe ist
ziemlich groß denn in denen denke ich
dass man es erwarten konnte dass so
etwas passieren und ich glaube auch dass
es nicht so schnell aufhört die grenzen
muss eigentlich erst jetzt noch gesetz
werden durch eine regierung die noch
nicht geformt haben sollte wahl im märz
haben sich die parteien nicht auf eine
koalition einigen können die
geschäftsführende regierung von mark
rutte zerstritten über corona maßnahmen
musste seitdem bereits zweimal
lockerungen zurücknehmen die
ausschreitungen jetzt könnten zu ihrer
härtesten belastungsprobe werden
auch in österreich befürchtet der
innenminister eine radikalisierung der
korona proteste die sind in wien gestern
zwar eher friedlich geblieben aber unser
nachbarland geht ab morgen in einen lock
down der für alle gilt dazu zweig
beziehungsweise 3g am arbeitsplatz
österreich sieben tage incidents liegt
aktuell über 1000 britta hilpert
berichtet in wien sieht es heute schon
so aus wie in den nächsten drei wochen
alles dicht nur leben für den
lebensnotwendigen bedarf sind geöffnet
lockdown ab morgen impfpflicht ab
februar lästig aber notwendig meinen
hier die meisten russen krankenhäusern
passiert jetzt auch schon zwei wochen
früher sein können also ich finde es
blöd dass dadurch kommt dass die leute
sich nicht impfen lassen und wir jetzt
alle mit reingezogen werden wir haben
früher auch und sieben von lassen müssen
ist hat uns keiner gefragt und muss
leben nur immer auch sander und seine
mutter arrangieren sich der achtjährige
will aber weiter zur schule ich werde
einfach besser müssen aufgaben fertig
kinder und ihre eltern haben die wahl
kinder könnte kommen allerdings nur mit
maske und tests homeschooling ist
empfohlen dafür sollen lern pakete
bereit stehen die lehrer allerdings
haben noch gar nichts vorbereiten können
besser vorbereitet sind die impfzentren
die quote steigt seit einer woche ab
februar ist es pflicht bei verweigerung
drohen strafen und vierstelligen
eurobereich
verfassungsrechtlich sieht die
zuständige ministerin heute jedenfalls
krank punkt die regierung verordnet die
impfpflicht und den lockdown ab morgen
sehr plötzlich weil dringend im
vergleich mit deutschland liegt hier die
zahl der intensivpatienten um etwa ein
drittel höher und noch steigt die zahl
jeden tag skilifte und gondeln sollen
dem lockdown übrigens nun doch geöffnet
sein allerdings nur für anwohner hotels
und gastronomie sind geschlossen
friedrich merz mitbewerber um den
cdu-vorsitz sieht seine partei in einer
schweren krise wir haben bei keinem
thema mehr die meinungsführerschaft
nicht einmal in der wirtschaftspolitik
sagte er der bild am sonntag neben märz
bewerben sich noch kanzleramtsminister
brown und der außenpolitiker herr
röttgen um den cdu chef posten die
befragung der rund 400.000 mitglieder
beginnt am vierten dezember
in jerusalem wurden bei einem anschlag
in der altstadt ein israeli getötet und
vier weitere verletzt nach israelischen
angaben soll einen palästinenser am
eingang zum tempelberg das feuer
eröffnet haben kurz darauf ist er von
der polizei erschossen wurden der täter
sei mit einem maschinengewehr und einem
messer bewaffnet gewesen
ein lebenszeichen der vermissten
chinesischen tennis spielerin porsche se
präsident thomas bach hat heute mit ihr
gesprochen in dem 30-minütigen video
telefonat sagte die 35 jährige ihr gehe
es gut und sie bitte um respekt für ihre
privatsphäre
kurz vorher hatten chinesische
staatsmedien videos von ihr
veröffentlicht die aktuell sein sollen
die frühere weltranglisten-erste im
doppel hatte anfang november einen
chinesischen spitzenpolitiker des
sexuellen übergriffs beschuldigt und war
seitdem verschwunden
ja richtig gute nachrichten vom tennis
die gibt es jetzt mit norbert könig ja
sehr erfreulich aus turin tolles jahr
für alexander zverev geht zu ende nach
seinem olympiasieg ist er nun auch
tennis weltmeister und das zum zweiten
mal beim atp-finale in turin bezwingt
wäre im endspiel den russen daniil
medwedew glatt in zwei sätzen
der fall hat sein grandioses tennisjahr
20 21 alexander zverev spielt in turin
ein finale gegen den russen andrej
medwedew dass zu seinen besten spielen
aller zeiten zählt nicht einen einzigen
breakpunkt gewährte dem russen und dass
er das endspiel mit einem ass beim
zweiten aufschlag beendet sagt viel aus
über seine unerwartet große dominanz im
halbfinale den weltranglisten ersten
djokovic geschlagen und im finale den
weltranglisten zweiten mit wetter zum
jahresabschluss ist alexander zverev der
beste tennisspieler der welt
erste heimniederlage der saison für den
sc freiburg in der fußball bundesliga
eintracht frankfurt entführt drei punkte
durch einen 2 0-erfolg und verbessert
sich damit auf rang elf freiburg bleibt
dritter neue krone aufregung bei bayern
münchen nach josua kimmig müssen auch
die kollegen gabri musealer
choupo-moting und croissants nach einer
nach kontakt mit einer infizierten
person in quarantäne alle sind wohl wie
komm ich nicht geimpft das top ergebnis
im wintersport bobpilot francesco
friedrich hat in innsbruck igls nach
seinem erfolg im zweier auch den
viererbob wettbewerb gewonnen und
zweiter sieg nacheinander für lewis
hamilton bei der formel-1-premiere in
katar war der brite die chance auf
seinen achten wm titel durch einen
souveränen start-ziel-sieg rivale max
verstappen fährt von startplatz sieben
auf zwei vor zwei rennen vor schluss hat
hamilton nun nur noch acht punkte
rückstand auf den niederländer
sensationell platz drei für den 40
jährigen ex weltmeister fernando alonso
sebastian vettel wird 10
genug der zahlen dass vielen dank
norbert und wir blicken jetzt aufs
wetter das fast für alle was dabei im
norden viel sonne in der mitte wechselnd
bewölkt im süden trüb und etwas regen in
den hochlagen etwas schnee bei nordwind
höchstwerten zwischen 3 und 8 grad um
21.45 spricht marietta slomka im heute
journal mit rk ii chef lothar wieler wir
sagen danke fürs zuschauen